- What's the worry here, Nick,
you've lost some of
your talent as an actor?
- No. (laughs)
(mellow upbeat music)
(alcohol pouring)
What did he say?
- [Ted] He says he loves you,
but he went in a
different direction.
(door lock beeping)
(door handle rattling)
- I'm done, I'm quitting acting.
Tell the trades it
was a tremendous honor
to be a part of storytelling
and myth making.
- Ah, fuck, man, I'm
driving through the hills,
I'm sorry, one more time.
(mellow upbeat music)
We got another offer,
it's a million bucks.
It's to attend a wealthy
gentleman's birthday party.
- I would never do that.
- It's the easiest gig
ever, you play yourself.
- What do we know
about this guy anyway,
is he into something strange?
- It's not like he's gonna
want you to suck his dick
or fuck his wife or watch
you watch him fuck his wife.
- I wouldn't think so.
- Welcome to Majorca, Mr. Cage.
- The guy that owns this house,
what's his name?
- Javi.
- Is Javi gonna want
me to, ah, (whistles)?
- I am Javi.
- Nick Cage.
God, this place is stunning.
- What is your favorite movie?
- That's one of those questions,
that's impossible to answer,
you can't just limit it to one.
♪ Imagine me and you, I do ♪
- Is it too much?
- Is this supposed to be me?
It's grotesque.
I'll give you 20,000 for it.
♪ I can't see me loving nobody
but you for all my life ♪
- I didn't know that was
a cliff, we could died!
(both laughing)
(mellow upbeat music)
- [Vivan] I'm in position.
- I think that's the
actor, Nick Cage.
- Nick Cage? I love you!
(camera clicking)
Have you seen "Croods 2?"
- I'm 44 years old, why the
fuck would I see "Croods 2?"
I've seen "Face/Off"
and "Con Air."
♪ Why you kicking the dog ♪
- What do you guys want?
- We're with Central
Intelligence.
Do you know who you're
spending time with?
One of the most ruthless men
on the face of this planet.
I need you to help
the US government.
♪ Let's kill this love ♪
Find a way into that room, Nick.
- I can see myself doing
more of this stuff.
I think I might have
a real gift for it.
- Good, because we got
another mission for you.
- No, no, no, no, no, no.
♪ Kill this love ♪
- Your friend is working
for the US government.
- Don't lie to me!
(mellow upbeat music)
Are those my golden guns?
- They're my golden guns.
- I don't wanna kill you.
- You're the last
person I wanna kill.
- I love you!
♪ You'd just be selling
me something dangerous ♪
I'm Nick, fucking!
♪ Rat-a-tat-a-tat ♪
(guns firing)
Whoo, Cage!
(mellow upbeat music)
♪ Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah ♪